I've taught my kids from day one you
know families everything so that comes
first the Kardashians are putting that
lesson from Mama Chris in action a
source close to the reality TV family
tells et they're in crisis management
mode and rallying around Chloe following
reports that her boyfriend Tristan
Thompson cheated on Chloe just days
before she's expected to give birth our
source says Chloe is still in Cleveland
where she had been sharing a home with
Tristan and plans to have the baby there
adding the baby is the priority
Chloe is focused on having a healthy
delivery it's moving really fast for me
Chloe is due to give birth to a baby
girl any day now but our source says
don't expect the mom to be to speak out
or make any statements about Tristan
right now the initial shock has yet to
wear off but as Ichi previously reported
the Kardashians are keeping Chloe away
from looking at the news quote her
friends are shocked and didn't see this
coming they seem to be in a really good
place and another source tells ET
Chloe's ex-husband Lamar Odom quote has
been telling close friends that he
genuinely feels bad for Khloe multiple
sources close to production tell ET
producers of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians are working to figure out
how Tristan's scandal will play out in
future episodes the family is currently
filming the show
[Music]